this is kind of a simple broad question
but
i think a lot about the nature of
reality and the purpose of everything
and
energy and frequency and what's all
happening and i wonder
what the point of relationships are
um
well i think that ramdas quote is so
apropos that we're all just walking each
other home
you know i personally believe that the
purpose of relationship is you know i i
think love
just might matter enough to us that
we're willing to look at our stuff
there's not a lot of other things that
matter to us enough and if you look at
the
deepest core human motivations is
connection and love and
i believe that it it is the
purpose and the evolutionary purpose and
i mean maybe from from both the
consciousness perspective and a personal
evolution perspective
is that relationships they are a mirror
to the things that we're not good at
they show us where we're not free they
show us where we wear mass they show us
our potential like you think about
everything that triggers you is really
an invitation to learn mastery and the
thing you're triggered about because the
trigger itself is this hypersensitivity
to
likely a pre a previous wounding that
just hasn't been processed exactly right
so like when the trigger comes forth we
vehemently protect against experiencing
what we're afraid is going to occur
and that's brilliant intelligence but
what lives in the actual trigger is the
information of what skill would i need
to learn to at least mitigate the
possibility of this happening again and
i think
it
really when we can learn how to manage
conflict successfully when we can see
that it deepens intimacy of self and
other
that we actually can see that conflict
serves us you know it shows me
like why can we not navigate a
conversation
and actually
end up more in love
this is like cantonese for most i'm sure
right like
think about it would be for younger me
yeah younger me and that's why i'm
saying like
to think that the conflict is the gold
in the triggering is the gold and is
where you can
mine to use gold yourself and figure
things out and expose those shadows and
expose those
patterns that aren't serving you and um
in areas where you're not free this is a
this is like a foreign concept it
totally is you know especially
except for the people who speak
cantonese then it's a natural you know
concept and in that there are people
that
navigate this language
and i think it's a massive revolution of
relationship you know ultimately like
you look at what we tend to have
inherited relationally is codependency
and
you know like if you look up your family
yeah wait you're at home uh if you look
up your family and it's me
same and you know if you look up your
family tree and really where we learn
about relationships is from our families
and our societies and our cultures and
our movies
if you never learned how to have
conflict and turn it into deeper
intimacy how the hell would you know how
the skill set is not shared but it can
be learned and eric fromm who wrote the
book the art of loving he has a great
quote in it where he says that there's
nothing that we fail at more than love
yet don't take the time to learn and
there's sort of this arrogance i think
to being human till it's gone
that we actually just think we should
just be good at relationship like
we have this narrative that you get
married by a certain age and you're just
supposed to make it last forever like
yeah
and you know people get a lesson on it
i got zero lessons on it and i went to
catholic school so i actually started
with negative lessons you know and i was
taught that there was a giant white guy
in the cloud with a beard that would
decide if i was a good guy or a bad guy
like it's so stupid and you don't get to
find out till you get to the gates like
how dumb is that
you know and so you see like how much
so much of you even of our perception of
self is externalized that
that god is outside of you that but
anyone's who's experienced love and i
forget who i think it's alan watts who
says
ask anyone who doesn't believe in god um
ask them that when they're having an
orgasm
you know i think there's this
there is a willingness when we've
experienced enough friction relationally
to explore the friction
and when we stop running from our
challenges relationally
and actually realize that you don't have
to run towards them because that's
definitely going to be awkward
especially after you've been running
from them
but when you start to actually just slow
down and turn around and turn towards
them and realize you know that
that's where the gold is as you said i
mean i i think the challenge
culturally is that we are taught to
avoid conflict
we are taught to
vehemently disagree and just
name call the other side
we're not taught the skills to build
bridges we're not taught the skills too
deep in relationship
we're taught that if someone has an
opposing view or an opposing way of
being that they're just wrong
and like this has perpetuated our
culture and this has perpetuated our
relationships and
you know i think we're definitely seeing
that especially now relationally
and you know really i think the future
for relationship but also culturally is
we all have to become bridge builders
we all have to become the people who say
hey actually there's another way and the
other way is about because you if you
return to developing a more sacred
relationship with yourself which is
inevitably what's going to happen
you know it's richard rohr who says that
the journey to finding the true self is
the same as the journey to finding god
and i love that because if you go to
find god you find self if you go to find
self you find god and you know kind of
speaking to what i said earlier the idea
that there's a differentiation between
those things is i think what is
weaponized against us sometimes but
that's a whole other conversation but in
this
return of your relationship to treating
yourself as sacred
is then inevitably
that you will accept nothing less than
sacred and also what you'll share with
your partner is sacred and then the
reverence that you'll have to your
partnership
will be so different but inevitably if
you do that
you will return to a sacred relationship
to the earth and to everything it's a
mirror both ways right it's
it's the mirror to seeing how you need
to change is what you then project you
know
and and the solution
you know
speaking to the things that we are
taught to avoid i mean we're we're
taught that sadness or grief or anger
that there's something wrong with us if
we have those emotions as opposed to
well what happens instead of looking at
it is there something wrong with you and
you said what's right with me that i
feel this way yeah how can i be informed
by that what's it asking me to change
you know i think that is also this idea
that
there's nothing to be found in the
darkness or there's something wrong with
the darkness i mean i've been through
a breakup that brought me to my knees
and
i navigated that breakup sober the first
time i ever navigated a breakup sober
and
i felt things that i had never allowed
myself to feel but
so heavy
the richest transformations for me have
always occurred
in those sort of like
roots to the ground yeah demand to be
felt
spaces like
burn it to the ground right no other
choice it has
alchemy it's just alchemy right like
it's like becomes
ashes that fertilize the soil for
something else to come through i agree i
think that's one of the hardest things
about
lessons and really especially
relationships is where it comes up the
most but family too not necessarily
romantic um
is that you really have to go through
the [ __ ] like you have to go through
that burning to the ground process which
i was i from my my my experience as i'm
like if it
hasn't brought you to your knees like
you said
then it's
you know the the deeper you go into that
sadness and that depression and the
um self-reflection
um
[Music]
the the bigger the shift will be
and that sucks why does it have to be
like that it does you know it's the
irony too is that uh
that is actually what enriches love you
know like when you realize that when you
love somebody
you are constantly saying yes to losing
them right like you're saying yes the
more you love someone
the more you are actually increasing
your capacity
for loss you're actually as you love
someone feeling the grief of losing them
and
you know because inevitably you're gonna
die or i'm going to die or we're both
going to die but either way the
relationship's going to end
and
when we can confront that
and realize that actually in the
grieving of that is the experience of it
like when i look at my fiance and i
experience the
recognition that
i'm gonna die or she is
this relationship will end
this experience will end
then i'm actually able to taste
everything in the moment but the denial
of the death death of self death of the
relationship is to actually deny the
richness of the present
totally
so what an invitation grief is because
grief doesn't give you a choice and
when you can see that grief is there's a
saying that grief is love that has
nowhere to go oh yeah
and i don't know that it's meant to go
anywhere because i think of like some of
the most painful breakups i've ever had
or painful losses i've ever had like
they are just made richer although it's
hard to process them
i don't know i think that's probably the
closest i've ever gotten to whatever
might be the experience of god